si las esperanzas continúan pero como
usted bien lo decía yo son cuatro los
muertos y de hecho el número de víctimas
mortales ha venido aumentando en las
últimas horas sin embargo el alcalde de
Marsella dijo que continuarán trabajando
sin descanso como lo han venido haciendo
Desde la madrugada del sábado cuando
colapsó ese edificio en el centro de
Marsella a la búsqueda de alguna
sobreviviente cinco personas continúan
todavía sin no se tienen noticias de
cinco personas más de 100 bomberos
trabajan sin descanso de día y de noche
allí para pues poder remover los
escombros y buscar A estas personas en
muchas de estas labores habían estado
interrumpidas sobre todo por un incendio
que había bajo estos escombros pero hace
unos instantes ya las autoridades
dijeron que ya el incendio pues no
representa ningún problema así que todas
las labores de rescate con las brigadas
también de perros rescatistas pueden
llevarse a cabo sin ningún problema
ahora también el problema está para las
personas más de 200 personas que fueron
evacuadas de los edificios alrededor de
este lugar donde se presentó este
colapso porque hay que investigar si las
estructuras de estos edificios se vieron
afectadas o no En cuanto a las hipótesis
la que se la que tiene el digamos la más
privilegiada es precisamente la de una
fuga de gas que hubiera podido ser pues
la de El detonante de esta gran
explosión que todos los testigos de esto
Pues dicen haber escuchado en la noche
de este sábado